you
hello everyone and welcome to the third
episode I think we should call them
episodes of the project Euler in which
we're going to continue our journey to
solve the project Euler problems
okay so look at that my mouse
disconnected that's a good thing
how are you today
let me see if everything's right - let
me know if you can hear me
let's see alright I think we'd have a
bit of a delay so yeah just let me know
when you can hear me for those of you
don't know my name is Tory pop I'm a
software developer engineer program good
sorry about it
alright yeah I was checking the stream -
okay get so apparently it works so yeah
I was as I'll be saying I am for it pop
I am so far engineer I have a youtube
channel I do coding tutorials and live
streams and if we could camp I started
doing this project order challenges I
think three or four weeks ago and this
is the third part we did the first five
in the first stream then we did next
seven I think and now we're going to
continue I don't know how far we can get
I haven't prepared I mean I didn't
wanted to have the solution ready so
that we can solve them together which is
good because we can see how's the proach
maybe we have to Google some things to
learn about call-outs I guess we're
going to see when we get there yeah this
time the chat will be opened so make
sure you don't spam that much
[Laughter]
yeah so project Euler I saw someone
asking what project Euler is so is a
series of challenging mathematical or
computer programming problems meant to
delve into family
unfamiliar areas by the way I'm nothing
oh yeah
so my mouse apparently wants to die
today so basically it's coding
challenges and of the free code camp
curriculum we can do it in JavaScript
which is nice if you haven't saw the
previous live streams I suggest you go
and look over and also you should start
looking at them on your own and then
maybe check in with us to see how how
it's going all right let me see I have
here another battery to change my my
dynamic Mouse just a second hello
everyone I see so many people that's
crazy
ok let me change this yes sorry about
that but didn't know that my mouse is
being fancy today let's hope it won't
die again or I just have to use some
other batteries all right well if I
think the chat has a 30 second delay so
what I would suggest you use the chat is
for questions and okay let's see if this
works now for questions and if I get
stuck maybe you can help me last time
Laurent helped me a lot so okay so my
mic does I'm my mouse doesn't want to
work which is fun we're going to start
with the pause on the free code camp
we're going to use JavaScript okay
let me get some new batteries just a
second all this work
okay just give me a few seconds
painted
you
all right I have to go to get new pair
of batteries yeah it is a delay from the
chat and the live stream so keep that in
mind I'm not sure what's the latency but
it might be a delay of a couple of
seconds up to even 20 seconds so it
depends on how they setup the stream but
yeah alright hopefully now the mouse
won't die see this is a developer's
journey sometimes you your mouse will
die when you need it the most
okay good
taking too long to replace batteries
yeah I'm doing my best buddy
alright so let's see the problem we are
going to start today it's the large Sun
what is it about oh look at all these
numbers okay let's see work out the
first ten digits of the sum of the
following 150 digit numbers
okay
so I think we need to add up all these
numbers and keep track of the last 10
digits okay let's see we also have here
test number
[Music]
I think what they will provide us is
just this big number
yeah
but although I see here is an array
Oh 150 digit numbers okay so we have
these numbers which will be inside of an
array and we need to add them up and
only return the last ten digits
Papa reporting hello our pub okay so how
will we do this what I'm thinking is
that we basically only need the less
than digits of all the numbers we're
going to add them up
and then store the result in a 10 digit
number right I'm not sure that we need
all the number so for example this part
because they'll add up and do some
things let's see so we have 3 6 9 10 for
the test number we get
oh the first ten digits okay so now the
last all right for some reason I thought
that it's little less than digit
you
okay
so then we kind of neat add up all the
numbers
mmm
and we go up and store the less-than
yeah first and not last
okay
you
so let's see Laura do you have any ideas
how we can approach this I guess we can
keep adding the digits the good thing is
that they all have the same number of
digits right so we can kind of go one
digit at a time and store the result
yes some people in the chat are kind of
route so don't do that
not sure why
this is not as I said I don't have the
solution from the beginning we're going
to do it on it well at the first kill
and we're going to see the approach and
how we what's this well what's the way
to get to the solution so yeah yep let's
start by doing this approach we're going
to look over the string get the numbers
and add them up you know ending number
in a result numbers let's see how that
works
result number will be a string well or
we could use an array
let's try that so we're going to have an
array and we're going to take is in the
test numbers we have two strings which
is good so we have 50 digits we can go
forward i 0 i LS that 50 i plus plus and
here we can get digit 1 well be
well I kinda need let's see you know we
know that intestines we have to string
so we can do something like array of
zero and the index will be let's rate at
went fifty minus I so fifty - I right
because I is zero we want this digit
then I is one you said at the beginning
donate all digits for every number the
most rabid leads are able to the sum
well yeah we kind of need all the digits
right because they might add up and
change the last well the first then
right
try that so digit 1 digit 2 will be
array of 1 so this string and 50 - I
okay so we have the two digits and we
want to add them together
so result numb well we're going to push
digit one well let's just keep one and
two one and two so one plus two right
now this will work so here we're going
to have 0 plus 8 will be 8 5 plus 3 will
be 8 2 plus 5 will be 7 and so on
the only issue will be for example here
where we have 4 & 6 when we add them up
it will be 10 so we have one extra for
the next or than the next addition so we
need to account for death
okay let's see we could use a boolean to
keep track of that so has what may be
over ten and will be false so if one
plus two and we had variable numbers but
let's work with this and see how it goes
if one plus two is bigger than 9 so it's
10 11 up to 18 we want over 10 to be
true otherwise over 10 will be false and
here when we push we kind of want to
keep track of that also so 1 + 2 + / 10
if we have over 10 we want to add 1
otherwise we had 0
right
but then here we also need to account
for that right you might have so let's
see we have four we have nine plus nine
is 18 so we move one
let's see an example here yeah so this
is the perfect example 4 plus 6 is 10 so
we move one here and then 7 plus 2 is 9
but with one from the previous addition
we have 10 again right so let's create a
sum and do 1 plus 2 plus is over 10 we
can do this ternary thingy so then we
add the sum and then we check if the sum
is bigger than 9 if it is then we set it
true otherwise we set it to false this
should work so at the end now we're
going to have an array let's see result
now
and let's counsel that law get here we
should have an array oh there are
strings good good good good good so we
need to convert them to strings sorry
from strings to numbers yeah not a
number okay
fifty minus zero so we don't have an
index 50 we have an index 49 so minus I
minus one
thank you our pan in the name of liquor
can for your donation yeah yeah thank
you
yeah it's kind of a bummer some people
are just mean yeah and you can see other
issue we have now we are pushing the
two-digit numbers into the Sun and we
don't want that so we can do module stem
and then it will cut off that part okay
so now hopefully if we did a good job
we have the correct calculation for
these two numbers and let's see so we
start from the right and we need to end
up here so the first 10 digits we have
it other way around so the last 10
digits here
let's see do we have something yeah look
at that
8 3 4 8 4 2 2 5 2 1 so we have the
answer here which is good
which is pretty pretty good we just need
to get it up right okay so instead of
returning the result now we want to do a
result now that let's see slice minus 10
so the less than numbers we want to
reverse it like that we want to join it
as a string like that and we want to
convert it to a number like that so now
if we run this test we should solve the
first one here which is good
you
yeah that's true by the way for those of
you who want to chat and also want to
support this nonprofit which is very
helpful I think they helped hundreds of
thousands developers well guess if
Amelia's with the articles and
everything I don't know the numbers
exactly but it's very helpful I promote
them a lot if you want to support it you
can become a member and then well you
will be able to chat in the live chat
okay
good so we kind of have it for one well
with two numbers what we have here is
let's see 150 digit numbers so let's see
we can do it with the pairs of two right
I'm thinking
yeah so we can kind
to the pairs of two and then keep adding
to the number
[Music]
let's see
and all of them the number will get
pretty pretty big
so it will be more deeds here we have 50
digits but at the end we're going to
have probably 51 digits 52 digit 7 I
don't know
so we need to account for that
[Music]
let's see we could store the result
number in this array well we could store
the first number right in this array and
then add the second one to eight the
third one to eight and so on and so
forth and at the end we're going to have
this big big big number
is just that we're pushing here so that
means that when it kinda need to push
again
yeah it's not not the best approach I'm
thinking how we can do that
because we don't want to lose the first
n digit
you
you
[Music]
we could change the digit of the index
instead of pushing so this works with
two numbers but with more members might
get bigger and we need to count for that
or there is a better way can't think of
a better way now
you
so let's do it manually once so we're
going to add these numbers and these
numbers and so on and so forth and at
the end we're going to have a number
from these two numbers right which as of
now will be pushed in this array but
then we kind of need to use that array
and add up this number and the only
issue with this approach we are having
now is that well we kind of go over only
50 digits but this is the top the sum
might get bigger I know that in node I
think there is a big hint a library
which could save us but
I'm not sure here
because if we just add the numbers so if
you do something like
let's test nums of zero plus test noms
of one while this is concatenation we
can convert them to numbers
yes you can see that we have plus 49 but
we kind of have the do we have the four
digit Oh
okay we kind of have the digits here
hmm - welcome and as a supporter thank
you on behalf of wicked camp yes so I
think we over well we overcomplicated
this let's see I'm going to comment this
out just to save it for now and we're
going to return let's do the good old
reduce we have the accumulator the item
and we want to add the accumulator the
number parts in item
and we want to start from zero all right
let's run this and see what we get
well we kind of need this big number
[Music]
what happens if we say to string
a-and what happens if we do think
substring zero to ten
amazing
[Laughter]
let's see substring I always have to
look at substring so I want numbers I
think it's with like splice from 0 to
index
well
doesn't seem to work though substring to
really so what's happening
doesn't it work for two string
let's let's do this in the console as we
can see exactly what oops what it looks
like if it's a string it or if it's a
number
okay well look at all this because if
you have a number 8 plus 8 it's this
color say purple nice but if we have 8
plus 8 while we have the codes so
we can use this array like that and we
can apply the reduce on it like that and
you can see that we have a number so now
if we do two string oops
yeah we get the string so what if we do
substring now or substa let's zero ten
okay so here it works which is good we
kind of want not ten we want 12 because
well we have the dot two
it's inclusive so we want this and want
to replace the dot with a string
yeah look at so we add this although
there are strings and we get a a plus 49
not sure up to how much it goes and then
we use the reduce to add up all the
numbers inside accumulator then we
converted the string we get the 11
characters we want and we replace the
dot
seems to work let's see we use this here
so yeah basically what I did at
beginning it was pointless although you
can see that oh the console.log doesn't
work because we're having this oops so
we don't have the call of the large side
my bad sorry
large sum with the test numbs yeah look
at that
yep the only issue is that it's not the
number and we can convert it the number
adding a plus well look at that it was
much simpler than I originally thought
pretty crazy yeah sorry about okay so we
add up all the numbers with videos we
convert the string to a number and then
we convert it back to a string we get
the first 11 characters and we replace
the dot okay can I think if you save
this and we go to the next one I just
want to see if it will remain saved
okay overcomplicating added highest yeah
it doesn't oh well I guess we just have
to download the code
good doesn't matter how big the number
is it at the end you need the first ten
digit
I would throw away the very small widget
not sure what do you mean with that
all right good so let's see the longest
Kaulitz sorry if I mispronounced your
name or I don't I think it's a name
right who is this guy but or maybe not
the guy
it's conjecture okay
okay let's see what it says so the
following iterative sequence is defined
for the set of positive integers and
becomes half of n if n is even or n
becomes 3 n plus 1 if if n is odd I've
heard this before using the rule above
and started with 13 we generate the
following sequence so this is odd okay
and we end up to 1
yeah I sat down but and I just didn't
like it it can be seen that this
sequence starting at 13 and finishing at
one contains ten terms one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten yeah
although it has been proved well it has
not yet been proved sorry it is thought
that all starting numbers finished -
what
which starting number under the given a
limit produces the longest chain well
one the chain starts with terms are
allowed to go above 1 million once okay
so that's the read it again because my
English is not the best so which
starting number under the given limit so
we have a little limit produces produces
the longest chain note once the chain
starts the terms are allowed to go above
1 million
okay
this is interesting
we need to find which number produces
the longest chain okay
one way would be to do the brute force
and check for all the numbers created
create a sequence
and then see which is the longest but we
kinda don't want to do that
have another idea in mind
so yeah if we do the let's start with
that but you'll see that it will time
out eventually
so we have the limit and we need to
start which starting number under the
given limit produces under four let I
equals 1 I less than the limit because
we want under the limit we want to check
the sequence
so let's see we're going to write a
function which will do the calculation
and it will check
to see how long it will take right okay
let me think
so let's write the function check length
I'll check
call length of the number okay and here
we can do it a while number is different
than one right
oh and I guess we can start with two we
want to do this thing here so if it's
even if number modulus to zero we want
to do number
/ -
yeah Thank You Lauren by the way let me
know what's the delay of the chat let me
know when you hear this I probably may
need to set up a lower natural cold just
so it'd be totally faster okay so if the
number is even we want to divide by two
else we want to do three times number
plus one so this will be while is
different than one right
okay if number is one then want to
return what this will guess we can say
get call it slight otherwise we want to
say here length which will be zero and
here in the wire loop will increase the
length
plus plus and we're going to return the
line like that okay good now you'll see
that this won't be the best approach
because for every number we're redoing
all these calculations and it will
timeout but let's let's just start with
this and then we can adjust it okay
oh boy it's pretty pretty delayed okay
so we want to return the number for
which the length is the longest so we
want to save the number well D number
this will be I don't know this will be
two by default and then we want to say
the MaxLite will be zero so here we're
going to get a linked from the Catholics
length of the eye which will be the
number so we're going over all the
numbers right up to the limit we get the
length and now we're going to check if
length is greater than max length then
we want to do two things first max
length will be learned we want to
reassign the max length and we want to
change the number I just added D number
no it's not the best but we have the
number here so I want it to be special
and the number will be I and here at the
end we can return the number let's
console the clock this and they should
hopefully work you can see that for 14
it works
which is good well it worked for all of
them
oops yeah okay guess what I was thinking
that it will be way too many
calculations
because for this number for example it
will go up to 1 million so for all of
the 1 Million numbers or you can see
that why okay so up I guess
oh you can see sorry let me about this
so for 1 million numbers it will do all
this and it should take a lot of time
but apparently trans and it works so
then
we shouldn't worry I was thinking about
doing an approach where we kind of store
the numbers and their length so for
example we know that from five to one it
will take one two three four five steps
right from 13 to one it will take that
so I was thinking your Mac is too fast
I'm not sure if it runs on my Mac or
under servers yeah so what I was
thinking is to store these numbers and
whenever we go over a number and we
already have it so for 16 all right
let's sport to for example we have let's
see one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten yeah so for 13 we have
ten for two we have two right
although it's weird we only have one
step but okay
oh it accounts for the chain never mind
so if we store the to having the length
of two that it's chain to be two then
whenever we find two again we can just
use that right for example for five we
know that we have a length of 1 2 3 4 5
6 so we will just use it whenever we get
a number which is 5 instead of doing the
calculations again we already knew that
for 5 at 6 right
memorization okay Thank You Laurent yeah
something like that
but because it works yeah something like
a cache so I was thinking to have a big
object with key value pairs then number
on the left and the length on the right
and we could always check if we have
that number in the object then we could
use probably a set will work better but
I
it said that much so oh wow
it works like this that's a challenge
for you if you want do the second
approach I will just move on because it
will probably take a lot of time and
well I guess we better do another one
right okay let's see
lettuce pads or Latisse pads hopefully
it not miss pross it starting in the
top-left corner of a 2x2 grid and only
being able to move to the right and down
there are exactly six routes to the
bottom right corner
how many such routes are there to a
given grade size
okay this is interesting
I have no idea how to do this yeah
this will be the end Lauren do you have
any idea how we can approach this
oh boy so
mmm-hmm
and thinking now
here
and we have two choices
then here we if we reach here we have
two choices here we only have one choice
I'm 100% sure that there must be some
kind of algorithm but I don't know which
one
but the heavy mind is using the matrix
well
checking all possibilities
[Music]
let's see
yeah this is fun
okay so can we find out
how many approaches are therefore from
the point so here we have one two three
four points which can go one two ways
and one two three four points which can
only go one way
and that's six
let me write this down for a two-by-two
do have topples in JSI solved it with
arrays of positions like x0 y0 and start
topples not sure
those are also
yay
so we don't have a lot when it comes to
or we have six routes for a 4x4 we have
70 routes that's a lot 420 we have that
number
4:9
to 640 thousand six hundred and twenty
you solve it with arrays of positions
how far you I see you've played a lot
wait the project Euler how far are you
ah
so we could do with X&Y as you said
let's say so this will be 0 0 0 1 0 2 1
0 1 1 1 2 & 2 0 2 1 2 2
and
yeah I don't really have a clue
we could because let's say we're well we
are here right so we can go to the right
and down
and well when we go to the ride
we can only go one more
yeah
these problems are getting harder and
harder
let's see if we as I said from here we
have two directions here - here - here -
and just one there we kind of have an
eight
what will be the result for three I'm
thinking if we can kind of use that
number somehow
because there must be a formula I'm sure
there must be a formula I'm just trying
to guess what could it be
and very curious what's the the number
for three and maybe we can see a
battered should I start drawing those
yeah
so one two three or five six
one two three four five six now
a position like 0 0 plus move right is
like adding 0 1
move down its what zero
but yeah but then you have one two one
two
or will you go here also and let's see
one too
but then you kind of end up to it too -
yeah
[Music]
I wish we had the the solution for three
maybe we could find a pattern then
one two three one two three
a formula 2 but it's super advanced Matt
and I do not understand it yeah 1 2
how many can you run your I wouldn't
want to to draw four 3x3 could you run
your script and tell me how many routes
we have for three and maybe then I can
think of something help me out here
Lauren this is why I want to do maybe we
can find some kind of formula or wait
think about it kind of have something
but yeah for three yeah I'm going baby
steps
hmm this is interesting
let's see what Google says about Latisse
pads maybe we read some documentation
and
nor days of this pad
combin atronics a lot this pad is in
well a lot of things here I don't
understand I am NOT very very Matty
person though keep that in mind
these pets are often used to count other
combinatorial objects similarly there
are many conventional objects that count
the number
UPI is
think here
[Music]
okay
yeah pretty interesting
you
Northeast Latisse pads have close
connections to the number of community
come by nations which are counted by the
binomial coefficient and arranged in
Pascal triangle
okay 4x4
74
seventy okay is it cheating because
looking this up hope not it's not we
make the rules
so I see the Pascal triangle here which
is you have ones on the sides and then
you kind of add them up as you go
right
so one with one it's still
one with 2 is 3 1 which is 4 1 is 5 K 4
with 6 is 10
with tens fifteen fifteen or twenty
thirty five thirty five seventy okay so
the numbers and diagonal is like you can
see here we have six
which is for two by two right six
and then for 4x4 sorry I think for 3x3
we have 20
and for 4x4 we have 70
and I think wait if we go this down this
road we get the number so let's see the
next one
5x5 will be something like
six
20:21
six okay let me think again so here will
be half six here we're going to have six
plus 15 which is 21 here we'll have 21
plus 35 which will be 56 and 56 plus 70
will be
what 126
yeah but we need this number so that
number will be 126 times 2 252 and we
don't have 4 5
but I guess that will be number okay
but how can we code this
now our approach will be well pretty
much the same but the other direction
here we have northeast but we want
Saudis soda straight down and right
I'm thinking of an approach to heaven
array
let's see so we need a triangle which
will look something like this 1 1 2 1 1
2 3 2 1 right
yeah
one two one wait no so one one one okay
so I missed a couple of steps one one
and then we have 1 2 1 and then we have
1 3 3 1 ok so they add up so one
does anyone understand what I'm doing
here something like that but the next
one will be one
for sorry this is three six four one
right so we can need to go down these
three
and we get our result this will be our
fort so the center of this number will
be 2 by 2 which is 4
ya know so forth - how can we find it so
two by two is four and we have the fifth
row from the pyramid I guess let me move
can I move everything to the right yeah
I want to the next one and the next one
so two more
1 5 10 oops this kind of going to put 0
here well let's start let's star 5 & 1
and here we have 1 6:15
well 15 will be this it will have 30
and on 2010 plus 10 so 20 will be X I'm
going to write down what we have here 6
& 1
ok so we have a star to be 10-pound to
be 15 or no as that's the hashtag X to
be 20 okay so if we want the 3 by 3 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 and the seventh number here in
the center hmm so this is what we want
for 2 by 2 this is what 1 4 3 by 3
Oh one two three okay so they kind of go
odd number of fashion I guess this is
per one by one
2x2 3x3 okay now how can we convert this
into code we need this pyramid and if we
find this out we'll going to solve the
problem it'll be another approach that
you took Laurent but oh well we should
eventually reach that okay I'm thinking
so here we have an array with one digit
with two digits 3 sorry yeah an array
with one I had one number two numbers
three numbers four numbers yet so our
array should look something like this so
first one will be this
yeah this is the PI well let's see I
don't want to mispronounce - yeah
Pythagorean treat a Pascal strike okay
yet so we can use that good so first one
will be dead the second one will be one
one the third one will be one to one the
fourth one will be 1 3 3 1 okay how can
I get from this to this
sing sing sing sing tink
so we could kind of start with an array
which has this just the 1 and the 1 1
and then when we construct the next
array we do this Plus this now doesn't
work
we kind of have always except for the
first one we have ones and deep sides
and then the middle this one will be
tasted
but then this one will be these two okay
okay your your was brute yeah probably
your was better and just I don't know
doing the baby steps to hopefully get
there okay
have an idea we start with this array
and for the next items we do we go over
the element well when we construct this
array we'll put one and one at the end
and in the middle we're going to go over
this array and add up the numbers right
now when we construct this array we put
1 and 1 on the ends and then we add this
2 and this 2
and so forth right good so then we're
going to have the pyramid and our answer
oh I can't got it so our answer will be
let me think
so the array des with backtracking yeah
I think Thank You Michel in for donating
the to two pounds thank you in the name
of picker camp yeah probably that will
be a better approach but I don't know
those I think starting with these
problems I kind of have to learn more
about all all the other items and stuff
but yeah thank you thank you for joining
and for donating okay so yeah where were
we
good so we're going to have our past
call triangle I could it could just well
I couldn't do it for all these numbers
but yeah we're going to start with this
and the next item so first we need to
figure out how many items we want to
have and then when we create the last C
so this is the answer for the one by one
this is the answer for two by two this
will be the answer for three by three
sorry so one two yeah this will be for
too much yeah exactly
twenty
okay so we need this Pascal triangle
linked to be
let's see for 2x2 we want it to be five
four three by three we want it to be
seven one two three four five six seven
so 3 times 2 plus 1 2 times 2 plus 1 the
next one will be 4 times 2 8 plus 1 okay
good so we're going to do a for loop for
let I will be 0 and we're going to go up
to great size times 2 plus 1
and we're going to start with index two
because we already have these two there
yeah now in the Pascal triangle we want
to push something okay I forgot here I
pause pause so we want to push something
this something will be the new array
which we need to construct based on the
previous array
yeah kind of Hecky but hopefully it will
work
so prove prover a will be
well let's just call it triangle I'll
just call it three easier to type three
three and try Hey okay
index I minus one so we're going to get
this array and for this array we're
going to use the previous array and we
want to do something with it create next
light using the previous light let's
call it that hopefully it makes sense
for you it does in my mind but who knows
okay and the next create next line we're
going to use a line function and here so
what you want to do first we want to
have a line array now so we get that
line
new line will have an array of one and
one and in the middle
oh you know what we can do it like this
have a 1 and new line that push a 1 at
the end so we have this part right
okay and we need to construct these
numbers so how are we going to do that
we have a line we want to go over the
line
so for let hi zero I less than line that
length if I could type I plus plus
length again and here we want to add
Const um well be line of I plus line of
I plus 1 so this one and this one and
then in the next loop if we are here and
want construct these two we get these
two and then this do okay and we want to
go up to the last number so we don't
want to get this because we don't have a
number after it okay and the new lines
are going to push the new item then we
push that one at the end and then we
returned in your line
does it make sense hopefully does let me
comment this out let me counsel that
plug this and now if we did everything
right at the end here in the three array
we should have this look at that how
beautiful like it okay and what we're
searching for is pretty much this number
so the last array the middle number
so const last ray will be try that a
slice minus 1 and const medial number
will be less the ray of index less tray
that length
so let's see this one is one two three
four five six seven eight nine and we
won the element at index zero one two
three four so
/ - and met that floor right now n
divided by 2 is 4 point 5 then we delete
the 5 at the end of that 5 and we get
the middle number
Lester ray
okay something's not good so we slice
let's see the last three
oh so it's
oh I see so we don't want to slice here
we kind of want to get a last item my
bad
so three that length minus one okay get
so then we have the last array or the
last line I think we can use that last
line just be more thoughtful about it
and then the middle number will be
seventy okay Hey look at that it worked
yeah a lot of thought process about it
well behind it and we kind of needed to
see this
and when we had that well yeah so it
might be cheating maybe not we did it
well we didn't copy anything so we
created our own so yeah
it's not cheating right okay I hope
everything's working so we can go to the
next one I kind of want to download this
let's see yeah good save that there all
right
yeah
hopefully you got it
it was probably the hardest one we did
so far
okay let's go to the next one
Apple it'll be easier
all right so let's see
problem 16 power digits son 2 ^ 15 is
32,768 and the sum of its digits is 26
what is the sum of the digits of the
number 2 ^ okay
this will be interesting I guess if we
do consult a clock here so we see the
result and if we do net that pao2 to the
exponent okay
Thank You Laurent so for 15 it works for
128 yeah so that was something I was
afraid of and for 1000 we get this
number
oh hey
and we need to add up the digits of this
number we have here a plus so this
number has 302 digits
pretty nice weight pretty nice
not really but what happens if we do
/ 10
so I'm thinking if we could somehow
get the digits okay we could use Martin
and divided by 10 to get digits I think
but yeah okay
the big number will be this and the Sun
will start with zero and while the big
number
well big number is
the big number is what so we keep
removing the digit so
for example if you happy 15
we want to remove this digit add this
digit plate remove it so on and so forth
so while this number is bigger than zero
cheating will be to use the formula
directly round sickles okay so let me
copy this this will be the formula for
the previous one so two times n
factorial divided by n factorial times n
factorial okay it is crazy
nice yeah so this was the formula for
the previous one
pretty clever but who knows I knew they
had to be some kind of formula because
at the end is PI tag Pascal's triangle
and it has all sorts of crazy things
going on okay let's get back to this one
so while the big number is bigger than
zero we want to do something like that
some plus equals big number modulus ten
and big number divided by ten well I
guess we can do mat that floor big
number by ten
he's big only okay okay it's really not
bigger all right so some twenty six
again this works for this number this
should work for 128 yep so we kind of
miss there something yeah
what about one thousand
okay
thing is not working correctly what is
it
they kind of lose I think
what if we don't floor
yeah
[Music]
we want to chop off digit
[Music]
can we do
it should work though yeah
so it chuff's the numbers but
yeah let's also see
cause last digit
I hope it is and we add this I want to
see what's the last digit also will it
get it right six four zero two four six
six four four eight
[Music]
[Music]
0:06
why is that six
oh oh well yeah that's weird though
see here it works here it works here it
works here it doesn't work anymore
that's weird
why is 8
you
you
why is this 0 6 and this 8
is there some JavaScript shooter or who
knows
oh you know what occurred instead of
doing this I could just say to string
and substring minus one
and here we're going to add the last
digit like that
so apparently no sub strings oversteer
okay good yeah
this seems to work better I don't know
these numbers though
so hopefully these digits are good yeah
not really
you can see that it gets this +10 38
we don't want that
[Music]
you
you
another approach I still get confused
why I didn't work with modulus tan
you
I'm thinking what would what could we
here
[Music]
let's see something else I want to check
its modulus tan what's the difference we
have 1 6 56 and we need 166 so it's a
10-digit different but then well then
difference here is 8 here is 8 here is 6
so that's probably they should
you
you
and I don't know how else could we do
because we get these plus 38 so we go
don't get full number with begins we
could have done it
Oh
you
do we need to convert to an array of
digits and just store everything in our
array
I wouldn't find that
[Music]
you
and thinking so if we do that we start
with two and then we multiply by two
we get four to six yeah
you
so multiplication with two is like
adding the same number twice right so if
we have
ace
an array with these digits and we want
to have well the duplication of this we
just add this number again and we can
add each number with each number like
that
in your array
the reason why I want to convert this to
an array because it will be easier at
the end to use reduce and get all the
digits although I'm still yet surprised
why modular standing doesn't work maybe
because the number is too big huh weird
so I guess let's do that approach
I'm thinking so we start we're going to
have summer if we start with two then
four then eight then not 16 but either 1
6 or 6/1
you
then we have not 6 1 + 6 1 so 6 + 6 will
be 12 so we keep 2 1 plus 1 will be with
2 and with the one before will be 3 and
if we do this approach at the end we're
going to end up with well this number
but in our array
can just add up the digits
so how we do this so we go over the
digit
and we multiplied by 2 and if the number
is bigger the next loop will get +1 okay
kind of tricky but yeah let's keep this
here and I'm going to do this sort of
thing how far we need to go
well we're going to the for loop okay
so let array will be a two and four let
me push this up a bit for let I less
than zero sorry I - 0 I less than
exponent so if we have 2 then we
multiply it once ok that works
yep so now we want to go over the digits
of the array multiply them and if it's
bigger than 10 we want to move the digit
we kind of did this before right
so yeah array that 4 but I think we're
going to change this array
because money we get from eight to six
one which is sixteen we kind of need to
push a one there at the end which will
be interesting
Oh so for let J equals zero J less than
rate of length J plus plus and here what
we want to do so array of J will be
array of J times two
good if array of J now is bigger than 9
1 turay of J to be
J modulus 10 so we chop off D well
second digit and we want to keep track
of some kind of boolean let over 10
we kind of did this before this will be
false and if that's the case then over
time
we'll be through else over ten will be
false
okay so we multiply it reverse the array
yeah well I want to rather push
- then pop you know because we the
multiplication is kind of from there
right of the side of the number right if
you have something like 1248 times 2 you
do something like this right so we do do
2 times 8 16
oops and then we keep 1 + 2 times 4 is 8
plus 1 is 9 then we have 4 + 2 right so
that's kind of the approach you do this
is why I'm doing the numbers reversed so
when you multiply you just go well hope
it makes sense okay so we multiply it if
it's bigger then we chop off the digit
and with over 10 is plus okay and we
kind of want to do the same thing here
again let's so yeah new value I guess
will be this plus over 10 if it is then
we add 1 otherwise we had 0 and the new
value will be this and
if the new value is bigger than nine
then we chop off that digit and we add
it to
yeah okay yeah over ten will be through
so we had it next time all right yep
this should
do something not sure yet what let's
return the Ray let's see what we get
yeah okay he definitely didn't work so
why is that Jay so it goes over the rail
length nope
it should go
so it goes once
Oh
so we kind of want
here if over ten at the end if we still
have over ten then we want to do a array
that push one so yeah yeah find out so
this works now what we did is that so we
have 2 4 8 16 so when we have 16 we kind
of did 8 times 2 we added 6 but then we
didn't have one so we kind of want to
push one at the end and now hopefully
well if we do let's see 2 to the power
of 10 should be okay that's to the power
of 11
yeah so two to the power of ten is 1,024
two to the power of ten
yeah 11 is this so we're off by one why
because we start here so let's do minus
one okay yeah to the power of 2 is 4 to
the power of 3 is 8 16 32 and so on
yeah so we have all the digits now even
for this big number
look at that and at the end here we want
to use our dear dear reduce method
accumulator item box item 0 and voila so
this just adds up all the digits in this
array well all the numbers and there we
go for 1,000 we have 1366 for 128 we
have this and for 15 we have this if we
run this should work let's download it
and move on but let me go over again
hopefully you understood it but let's
see we can remove this although and I
don't know why this didn't work in why I
didn't get the last digit correct but
nevertheless we just created the number
and edited digits in an array under the
calculations and at the end we add up
all the numbers hopefully this makes
sense
it does in my head but yeah alright
let's go to the next one how much time
we have left we could let's see the last
one and if it's too hard we're going to
leave it for the next one
or the next session if not we're going
to date today let's see number letter
counts okay if the numbers one two five
I've written out in words oh boy
one two three four five
then there are three plus three plus
five plus four plus four letters in
total all the numbers from one to given
limit inclusive or written out in words
how many letters would be used note do
not count spaces or hyphens for example
three four to three hundred and three
hundred and forty two contains twenty
three letters and 115 contains twenty
letters the use of end when written out
numbers is a compliance with British
usage he's in compliance
so okay let's see one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
seventeen eighteen nineteen twenty three
3 + 7 10 13 + 8 10
six plus so many sevens 13 plus one two
three four five six seven okay seven at
8:20 all right okay okay okay okay okay
good good good but not so good let me
drink some water
you
okay
the good part is that we only go up to
1000 inclusive limit inclusive so
[Music]
yep no thinking we have so many
variations
so let's write them down 1 is 1 2 is 2 3
is 3 4 is 4 5 6 7 8 9
and then we start with 11 so right 13
let me know if I ride them wrong
14 if
you
hopefully right tomorrow all right
heaven throw them in a way sixteen
seventeen eight he'd
this doesn't look right
if he'd
yeah okay so it's 15 not five teen okay
19 and then 2030 the good part is that
we start with days 40
50 60 70
baby
a tea and
[Music]
okay which one did I mess up hopefully
it didn't because well pretty much these
are all the different ones starting with
100 well 100 and then we have 200 300
600 and we can kind of use this so if
you have 638 700
50
for stolen and so far
who have zero oh boy
and we don't have zero to start with
with one okay
I'm thinking I'm thinking
let's just get some random numbers and
see if we can find some fancy way today
so 876 800
and of 842 115 okay
so we get the end also when we have over
100
many conditions
we could check
if we well by default and chair is
misspelled yeah true
thank you
we could start by checking
well what's the link
well I guess if a number bigger than 100
if that's the case then we already have
100 which is seven characters then we
have the end of Glee yeah if it's bigger
than 100 101 right 101 I think it's and
yeah okay 100 and so that's basically
whenever we have over 100 then we have
like 10 characters already which is good
we can get rid of that next
the only she will be with 1000 here but
yeah that's another story
if number is 100 well we can just return
that 100 right 100 I'm just trying to
think about some conditions we could use
and if the number is a thousand
one
thousand how do you spell that thousand
right thousand so that's eight that's
returned 11
oh wait so yeah oh yeah so it's good
it's good because then we need to add
them up okay good
wait what's there get now if it's bigger
than 100 we'll start with ten and then
well we need to get all the digits
let's see digits
the the number the string this will
convert to the string we want to have an
array of numbers use modulus he
yeah but the thing with modulus is that
so for the first one will work right
although if we have the second digit is
one then we kinda need to use this kind
of thing other than that yeah that will
work
so what I want here is the digit so we
have all the three digits
digits of zero this will be the first
one so the hundredths place we can use
this so if we have this as an object
count
yes
you
and for all of these instead of one we
have three here well we have the numbers
and letters right so here we have three
four two five four three so cumbersome
do but I guess baby steps
three four six five four seven five four
eight four four nine okay good
so that could work because now we have
the digits of zero and we could use this
count so we can have count of digits of
zero to be added to the son
kind of right because for example if we
have eight hundred and something we
first add
Oh eight
dead
could be a fixed number so we don't yeah
all right
wink wink
yeah
so many things to think about
what's the prettiest solution for this
problem
oh well so if we have eight hundred and
something we already added a hundred and
tooth be tan and then we kind of add so
if you have seven hundred the digit of
the first place will be seven so seven
is what five where but yeah it works so
we add five to the Sun now the only
issue is that if we have exactly seven
hundred
then we don't have that end so I guess
we can check here if number modulus 100
is zero because well wait one second so
this accounts for hundred
and
and here we don't have that hand no end
because we have exactly 700 600 so we
can start here with left some equal stem
and here we can just do some minus
equals 3 so we kind of remove that
and because it's a fixed number so 800
700 otherwise we have 700 and something
right hanging good
so we accounted for that
[Music]
okay
now we
for that digit the first one which was
easier
we're bigger than 100 a case we have
three digits the hundreds digit then for
the tens digit we have the digits of our
of what one now this will be tricky
any number other than
1 & 0 then we're going to use the days
oh boy okay
because if you have 890 something
but I guess this will be I'm thinking
thinking yeah it's just so brute-force I
don't really like it though
but yeah let's continue and hopefully
basically all of this will be a function
to get a word length and we'll get the
number
and here at the end we're going to
return the Sun if we have and some
otherwise we just return but whatever
whatever we want but well whatever we
have okay let me do this too so for 10
is 3
yeah I don't like the pro to do
so many test case
eleven is
office seven also
eight
you
seven again
you
9
eight
eight then here we have 26
six do we have any other special numbers
we need to worry about by five six or
seven seven now six
and six again okay this well we have
this here but oh well we already know
that this is seven
okay so what I want to do is whenever we
have so here we have the tens digit
right
then state it
if the tens digit is bigger than one
then we already can use one of these
right so we can do some class equals
count of digits but count of tens digit
plus zero this is the property of the
object we want which will be well seven
zero eight zero
okay now else if it's one we need to do
all of these thingies
the 11 and 19 could be Narae with index
1 tonight
yeah may be special case and well we
already have them here so I guess we'll
work with this object properties so if
it's one we kind of won the count of ten
digit plus the well last digit
what's that D let
let's ditch I don't know how it's called
the digits of two
last digit
so heck so so heck well and the last
digit we kind of want string it so last
digit so if we have something like 1/7
sorry this is not the house if one
so if it's 816 so I want 6 1 & 6 60
and well I'll sit zero so then we go to
some plus equals count of less digit
at six and six
806
but here again we could have 0o but we
kind of check that there okay
all right so we don't have to worry
about that we don't have to worry about
that now we kind of did probably if we
didn't mess up anything we didn't
numbers
over 100
does it over about ten
you
[Music]
I guess I'll save just to be clear digit
is zero then we just add the last digit
okay yes something's wrong here what
Oh
all right let's try our function which
should hopefully
give us the right answer for this
and this Oh Polly let's see
cancel the clog get word lengths of 340
some is not affected good let's start
wait wait wait wait wait sir yeah let's
uh equal to all right so now it's
defined 21 close but that really
[Laughter]
speaker than 100
it's modulus by 100 is not zero so we
don't subtract so we have 100 and yet so
that's one two three four five six seven
and yeah okay next we split the digit
let's see digits what we have here three
four to get here the sum will be
threes of
Oh
okay fifteen by fifteen console dot log
we put one here and some and here we put
two and the Sun just to keep track
okay so it's ten then three yeah this is
five
all right good so that's the next up we
want to see so 340
port so it's bigger that means that we
go here three so three plus some so we
get 40 which is 640 okay good
oh and we didn't do the last one
well I guess this is just the last digit
so if a last digit is bigger than zero
we just do this right
okay - one two three good
what's rock 4004 at 4040
sorry yeah and then this is wait wait
wait wait wait what I did so for T and
this is 5 and this is I guess for teen
forty now let's do it y-yeah or Tina gay
so that's eight
[Laughter]
all right
so we get 23 which is 23 which is good
let's see for 150
get plenty for
115
yeah
so we go here we add this
yeah I guess
if it's one
then we need to do this if the digit is
1 so 115 we don't care about the last is
what otherwise we kind of care
so if tens digit is different than one
then we do this
so hacky
but it works which is good
oh boy
started to get tired so 4:14 I guess all
this should work what else let's try for
667 so let's see 667 so we have three we
have seven
three
five
and five wait a total of ten turn 23 23
okay so apparently this works now the
only issue well one of the issues is
that we don't account for numbers less
than 100 for which we kind of need to do
this thing
okay so let's remove this from here
[Music]
delete
yeah
it's not defined okay
because data digits here
okay so let's do this digits up here
getting so complicated it's hard to keep
track
and it's probably buggy
so if that's the case digits of one zero
I guess what we could do is
get the digits and reversed
and now instead of digits of 0 we have
bits of 2 because it's the last one if
the numbers bigger than 0 would then 100
if it's 100
and that it's good
2007 okay we can keep that and now
instead of having tens digits the same
but this will be zero alright so now we
kind of reverse the number and we first
check if it's bigger than 100 we add
what we want for 100 otherwise we kind
of do our thing with digits and less
digits and all that so let's see four
five
we should get fined for 504 what about
17
9 is that true 17 9 yeah look at that
what about 10 3
okay what about 110 so 110 she's 3
seven
three three that's a total of sixteen
well it's all folks
what about thousand
you
1,000 hopefully that's 1000 so 3 plus 3
6 8 11 all right so let's do one more
what about 67 so 67
which is five plus five ten
look at that works
okay
you
yeah so we have the special cases
we have another console somewhere this
but now this function
should hopefully work properly and we
can kind of go over here to let some for
left eye's one I less than limit I plus
plus and here we just get word length of
i and some plus equals and return some
okay and here we cancel that log son
which were five is fifteen all right so
it's not good yet let's see why
you
[Music]
okay Const length will be days I want to
debug it so I put it here add it here
and then I do concern that log I and
linked I want to see all the light
okay oh I see it didn't go up to five
maybe that's the only issue we have them
correct
look at that pasa
what about 150
well that name of the castle now we
missed by four okay what about one
thousand
we miss by 20
so probably
one of these is messed up
thirty how do you call those numbers so
11 12 13 13 some of probably some of it
is messed up
and probably deaths Oh 16 hopefully
that's the issue otherwise
96
well we kind of don't use this so
bye-bye let's go back to this okay
what would be the issue or characters
difference
[Music]
you
nine eight seven
so yeah just something very very very
so it's a number which only pairs like
four times
you
whoa look at that I got it
this is six not seven and this is also
six look at that nice so that was the
issue
perfect okey this was totally mess but
well we kind of have it now which is
good let's run the test and let's
download the solution save it and never
speak about it again I'm so securities
how someone else did it
let's see from project Euler def net
here we can can act on my location
we can go to this numbers letter counts
and I think I need to sign Ain
let me do it of off-screen although not
sure what's my
you
I have no idea what they used
guess let's register
you win the spelling bee contest for a
non-native English speaker I am pretty
happy okay
I want to create a new account here I
think here on the platform if we submit
okay so username taken so I can create
that let's see awesome so I managed to
log in you can see that they did a
couple here so what I want to do go to
17 let's see if the number that the
hominin would if all the numbers from 1
to 1000 inclusive were written out in
words how many letters would it be so we
already have the answer which is this we
can check
this broad platform only gives you the
problem and then you need to submit the
number all right so now we can go to the
archives and
wait
you
and see how else people did it
I've see their love
of
Java C C++ can I check JavaScript for
some reason
now
you
I think yeah I had some issue sorry
about that I had to restart the Mac but
yeah this will probably cut off from the
livestream
[Laughter]
yeah but I am back yeah so we were
looking at at what some other people did
to solve this
hopefully went back let me know if you
can hear me
yeah okay I can see myself alright sorry
about that
so yeah
you can see here that one I know one
person Harvey mojo did something similar
with what we had if it's less than 20 if
it's less than 100
okay
and oh boy let's bite another thing can
we have something I know but yeah pretty
similar approaches can find Java crypt
probably no one directly JavaScript
let's see
this page nope
this page yeah I won't check all the
pages oh wow yeah so you need toward
decimal to word that small word
probably smarter than I had but yeah oh
well all right thank you all for joining
I'm sorry for the interruption at the
end hopefully yeah it should have picked
up yeah let's run this submit and way
completed that - so today whoa look at
this
why don't I have my that's weird
all right yeah that night works so today
we completed five more challenges which
were pretty tough especially
[Music]
this one no the this one this one was
the toughest but well with a bit of
goo-gooing and thanks to our Wikipedia
buddy we could find out one solution to
solve this all right thank your for
joining I hope you enjoyed it I hope you
learn something feel free to continue
the challenge feel free to do with them
on your own next week we're going to
continue and see how far we can get
thank you for joining have a good day
and I'll see you next time bye